sometimes this only doesn't always happen but sometimes you get people that are kind of more pushy
so when you say well i can't promise like you said you know i care that you shouldn't care that
you're getting 100 leads you should care that you're actually making money then they sometimes say
well what kind of guarantees do i get then like what if you know and then one way that sometimes
that i've worked around that that has worked is by saying well kind of like you said um it doesn't
matter like i'm not going to be able to promise you because i would be lying how many leads are
coming in but what i can promise you is that i'll make sure that every month you're not going in the
red meaning you're not going to spend money with us and you're not going to make anything
you know what i mean and if that happens that ever happens where you're not even breaking even
we'll definitely have a talk and we'll work something out and i think that's what you personally care
when you have a business so if you say that usually they're like oh okay i don't have to worry about
you know not making any money or losing money with you i think that usually makes them feel
more reassured doesn't make sense totally makes sense what and another thing that i like to say
to people is i like to say like look there's no guarantees like they're just no guarantees the
only thing i can guarantee you know that stupid saying like the only guarantee is death and taxes
or whatever that's kind of cheesy but that's true and i just let them know i'm like look there's no
guarantees i've done this for many many many years i've made you know people thousands and
thousands of dollars and i would love to guarantee you but the truth is there is no guarantees
because we don't know what google is going to do tomorrow however what i excuse me what i can
guarantee mr business owner what i can guarantee mrs business owner is i can guarantee that i'm
going to be doing the same exact work that i did on bob's website that got this many leads i'm
going to do the same work and the same strategy that i did on joe's website that got the same
this many leads that i showed you i can control the work that i do and then we kind of have to
let the chips fall and that's just the truth and like that's that's kind of how life is so i'm
going to do everything in my power i'll be able to guarantee you that i'm doing the work i'll be
able to show you the work that i'm doing i'll be able to show you the steps that i'm taking
and show you they're the same steps i'm taking on these other projects but at the end of the
day there's no guarantee they're just i don't own google it's just how it is they could change
something tomorrow now i i that's not what i think is going to happen but i just want you to
understand like that's just how it is there's no guarantees and just likewise you know i know bob
if i send you a hundred leads if i said to you how many are you going to close what can you answer
me that question and they're like well no okay exactly and if you don't close deals guess what
this isn't going to work either so you can't guarantee me you're going to close deals and
i can't guarantee you this is it is what it is we're going to do the best that we can we're
going to have open communication it's it's going to be a little bit slow in the beginning it's
going to be a little rocky it's going to be a little up and down some months are going to be
good some months are going to be bad but at the end of the day as soon as we get this website
ranked we can lower the ads we can have more consistent lead flow and we're all going to
make money but i need you to pick up the phone i need you to treat the customers well i'll do
my job you do your job but that's it like we just we need to the biggest key no matter what you say
there's no magic formula is stop over promising okay the whole time you're doing the sale the
whole time you're doing the onboarding all your communication you think that by over promising
by yes yes yes you know best case best case best case you think that's going to solidify the deal
i promise you it's the opposite be transparent be conservative be worst case scenario and these
people are going to trust you because no one's like that with them everyone wants to give them
the best case scenario and they're they just they smell bs